construction is moving along on Durango
station the newest Station Casinos
Resort coming to the Valley located at
the 215 in Durango right there at the
Durango curve Madison Kimbrough talked
to some in the area today about all the
traffic Madison takes us to the area
with what locals are saying
I'm shifted so I mean I can make
a little danger Nick Pace recently
opened Abel's Bagels located right off
of Durango near the 215 and if you step
outside his bagel shop you can see right
across the street the work that is being
done with Station Casinos set to open
their newest Resort Durango station
sometime later this year and while
construction is currently underway with
traffic congestion many people in the
area say getting to work surprisingly
hasn't been too much of an issue I know
right here in Durango there's a lot of
traffic I got to think when the
traffic's moving slow you know people
looking around they might notice our
sign so it might be really good for
Branding it has not affected the
business at all I haven't heard any
complaints about anybody being late
because of the traffic I have found a
way to get around it it's just that tiny
little area right off the freeway the
hundred thousand square foot Station
Casino will have a convention center and
entertainment space along with
restaurants a pool and a sports book and
the property is expected to create more
than a thousand jobs in the area I'm
excited for it I love new changes it'll
be good for the city more Casino shows I
think once it actually opens it might be
a little more traffic Madison Kimbrough
8 News Now